[Música]
imaginemos que estamos en un lugar muy
lejano en este caso nos encontramos en
china pero no estamos precisamente en
beijing o en una ciudad con millones de
habitantes sino que estamos en un pueblo
en un vuelo muy pequeño la gente que
camina alrededor jamás había visto una
persona como nosotros nos mira con una
cara extraña pero con mucha curiosidad
asimismo nosotros nos observamos los
distintos tipos de árboles que jamás
habíamos visto antes
[Música]
los pajaritos
y todos los olores que recuerdan algo
que posiblemente jamás hayamos visto
pero de repente detrás nuestro
escuchamos lo siguiente
marianela marianela mariana la malaria
y nos preguntamos de dónde vienes de
sonidos de dónde viene ese sonido como
qué pasó acá bueno yo les puedo asegurar
que ustedes no se imaginaban que iba a
arrancar la charla hablando de esto no
bueno yo les también les voy a contar
que yo tampoco esperaba estar unos meses
atrás en bolivia dando una charla en una
fundación y de repente escuchar
marianela esta canción que se me pegó
acá es que los de la república
dominicana la vez pasada y un grupo de
20 jóvenes bailando marianela marianela
marianela marianela ciencia pero no
entiendo nada bueno esto que le estoy
hablando este esta pasión que yo sentí
cuando me encontré con este grupo de
jóvenes hablando bailando todos en el
equipo se llama sentido de pertenencia
como pueden ver aquí el sentido de
pertenencia es la satisfacción que
siente una persona por sentirse parte de
un grupo
esto es algo súper importante de hecho
hay filósofos que lo toman como la base
de las necesidades
psicológicas del ser humano ahora vamos
a hacer durante mi charla vamos a
navegar por los distintos tipos de
sentido de pertenencia si íbamos a poder
analizarlo y vamos a poder entender en
qué momento nos están manipulando y en
qué momento podemos ejecutarlo
correctamente como podemos ver acá en la
primera ser descorteses en que estaba en
bolivia yo me enamoré de bolivia y hace
un año que estoy parando ya con mi
esposa estamos viajando desde argentina
hasta alaska en un auto que es un viaje
bastante largo como pueden saber y nos
enamoramos de bolivia la gente la
cultura una cosa hermosa entonces para
mí cada vez que de un grupo de cholitas
charlando para mí me hace acordar a esa
gente tan amorosa que me recibió en su
tierra algo similar a lo que me pasó con
marianela que estaban los chicos
bailando afuera ahora nosotros yo vengo
de un país del fútbol como pueden saber
por mi acento soy argentino y con mis
sobrinos siempre jugamos con el tema de
river-boca
es increíble como el fútbol es un
sentido de pertenencia tan fuerte que
hay gente que llega a matar por su
fanatismo ahora si yo les digo vamos a
hacer todo el tiempo un ejercicio como
ustedes ven había pasiones de tema pero
yo estoy supercontento a compartirlo con
ustedes y les voy a hacer una
comparación hay gente que sí que es
verdad que se mata por el fútbol pero
nos habéis visto el mundial el sentido
de pertenencia es mucho más arriba que
una que una elección de un país es hacia
el fútbol en sí y eso es maravilloso
pueden ver coreanos con las banderas de
argentina yo no porque a veces no sé
cómo pueden saber quiénes son nuestros
jugadores y eso es por el amor al fútbol
sentirse parte de ese sentido de
pertenencia nos une mucho más como
sociedad ahora en este caso en
particular elegir algunas fotos bastante
lindas al lado por ejemplo el de la
familia que ustedes pueden ver aquí ese
sentido pertenece al número uno es el
que primero tenemos cada vez que nace
vemos que nos criamos y demás ahora
imaginemos por ejemplo un grupo de
monjes budistas ellos se sienten parte
de eso correcto
pertenencia está muy arraigado a sus
costumbres por ejemplo hay una en
particular que yo me siento muy
identificado y les voy a contar después
porque qué tiene que ver con la meca la
meca más de uno de ustedes debe saber y
si no lo saben no pasa nada para eso
estamos acá tiene que ver ese es el
lugar donde los musulmanes se van una
vez en su vida al menos tienen que ir
bien y en la meca no importa cuál es tu
color de piel no importa tu nacionalidad
lo importante es la religión
es lo que ellos creen es lo que ellos lo
que los une ese sentido de pertenencia
voy a contarle una breve historia bueno
lo pueden ver al papá francisco que es
como un orgullo para los argentinos
obviamente los latinoamericanos pero
sucede lo mismo con la religión católica
no importa de qué color sos de qué país
venís lo importante es la unión que
sentís en ese momento en rezar en todos
juntos eso es algo muy hermoso y la
humanidad tiene algo muy hermoso con
esto ahora con respecto a la foto que
estoy están viendo ahí la de su
izquierda esa fuente de c's que di en
santa cruz de la sierra y casualmente en
bolivia que me hace sentir identificado
con todos ustedes yo soy y fui siempre
un fanático de las charlas ted inclusive
antes que estela x me apasiona
profundamente yo me siento identificado
en este momento de poder compartir con
ustedes este momento así como ustedes
han venido hoy aquí
tengo un amigo muy cercano de llama
rodrigo pero que también fue orador de
un té de saya y el día que nos conocimos
fue en un casamiento una cosa totalmente
espontánea y apenas lo vi nos quedamos
charlando es pelado igual que yo o sea
que ahí tenéis otra pertenencia más
y empezamos a charlar como y contar me
gusta dycasa la publicidad también si yo
también
yo también te una agencia no te puedo
creer y así prueba sos mi hermano
hoy después de dos años de amistad no
tengo mi teléfono como rodrigo hermanazo
y he vivido en su casa con su familia
conozcas toda la familia es que
realmente eso es lo que te da sentido de
pertenencia ahora no todo es color de
rosa en el sentido de pertenencia y hay
que prestar mucha atención ahora voy a
poner una parte muy seria de mi charla
que tiene que ver con lo que es la
identificación de los jóvenes
ustedes seguramente se habrán preguntado
cómo puede ser que un grupo extremista
pueda reclutar un joven bueno justamente
eso sucede cuando su sentido de
pertenencia está en crisis se utilizan
herramientas de manipulación psicológica
para conducir su agresividad y sus
deseos en algo que consideramos negativo
ahora esta va a ser la primera vez en
cualquier charla que he dado que voy a
abrirme profundamente hacia ustedes
y espero que no me ponga muy muy
nervioso y muy triste
yo tuve una gran crisis en mi sentido de
pertenencia cuando yo nací mi madre era
todo para mí todo a los 11 años mis 11
años ella fallece con un cáncer muy
fuerte y al año siguiente mi mejor amigo
lo que yo creía que era que era
justamente hijo de liliana mar y se
desmoronó completamente
ese sentido de estar solo eso esa
soledad profunda que yo sentía hizo que
en más de una oportunidad haya querido
quitarme la vida no me avergüenza decir
esto hoy es fácil decirlo estoy casado
soy muy feliz me va bien en todo lo que
hago estoy en una charla usted están acá
con los ojitos que estoy viendo ahí
adelante pero permítanme decirles una
cosa esto es mucho más común de lo que
nosotros creemos en nuestra sociedad la
chica que les nace en los pechos más
rápido y es más y sexualmente más
atractiva es la chica que es más popular
en el colegio el no pertenecer hace que
un individuo se sienta excluido y no
desee continuar su vida es algo muy
serio y vamos a abordar ahora el tema
del conflicto bélico que es el más
peligroso de todos
en mi país en 1982
tuvimos un episodio nefasto en el
momento que el gobierno de turno decidió
tomar por la fuerza de las islas
malvinas seguramente más de ustedes más
de uno de ustedes perdón lo habrán
escuchado
y es algo que nos duele muchísimo como
latinoamericano más allá de una cuestión
de ser argentino no las guerras siempre
son dolorosas para todos
si yo les pregunto a ustedes qué es lo
más importante que tienen en su vida
pueden decir desde su teléfono que
compran la semana pasada cambiaron el
auto lo felicito me alegro por usted es
su perro
en mi caso llevamos los perros
su padre su madre sus hijos
un hijo es lo más importante que tiene
un ser humano
una madre está creada para dar amor dio
a luz a su hijo y lo ama profundamente
pero su sentido de pertenencia
es tan fuerte que puede permitir que su
hijo lo más preciado que tiene en la
tierra vaya a una guerra y no sepa qué
puede pasar con él
la manipulación
seria que hemos tenido nosotros en
nuestro país en ese momento fue tan
fuerte
que esto era lo que mostraba en las
tapas de las revistas en ese momento que
estábamos ganando
hay una historia que me contó un amigo
mío que también casualmente es como un
hermano hoy en día que me dijo que él se
juntaba con sus compañeros a dibujar en
el colegio
y cartas para los combatientes que eran
muchas veces chicos de 18 años que
habían ido sin preparación militar
inocentemente el con solamente diez años
dibujaban los soldados mandando los
soldados del frente contrario
esto es algo muy profundo para tener en
cuenta y ahora que yo les estoy contando
esto y si le sumo encima el agravante
que yo nací en 1982 y que mi padre
quería ser voluntario para esa guerra y
debido al embarazo que tuvo mi madre de
mi él no fue y fue un tema que él
siempre no pudo nunca lo pudo superar
imagínense con todo ese contexto si
cuatro años después gracias al fútbol
diego maradona el barrilete cósmico
así el mejor gol de la historia de los
mundiales precisamente ante los ingleses
y vamos a hacer un experimento en este
momento y les pido a todos ustedes que
se imaginen y se posicionen en ese
momento y tratemos de escuchar con mucha
claridad el comentario de víctor hugo
morales
la tierra
tal vez
[Aplausos]
una vez
bien
[Aplausos]
garcía dios
[Música]
veo muchas sonrisas veo que se le están
parando los pelitos si tuviera más pelo
se me pagarían también
esto
es un ejemplo de sentido de pertenencia
en su máximo nivel
la misma plaza de mayo en buenos aires
que atraía miles de personas celebrando
la decisión de tomar las malvinas
se unió una vez más por una celebración
como puede ser que sea tan importante un
partido de fútbol
luego de haber entrado un conflicto
bélico es extraordinario lo que el
sentimiento de pertenencia puede ser
ahora vamos a cambiar de tema vamos a
irnos a la manipulación comercial
lo voy a hacer con un tono gracioso hay
una marca de cervezas muy conocidas que
tiene las mejores publicidades de hecho
si ustedes miran la botella su logo es
la bandera de argentina y es conocida
justamente por tener las mejores
publicidades ahora qué sucede
todos nosotros esperamos que sea el
mundial para ver las maravillas que van
a presentar en televisión ahora que me
cuentan si yo les digo que los dueños no
son argentinos
se imaginan ustedes una navidad sin la
botella negra en el centro de la mesa
es muy difícil verdad es lo primero que
no imagina el cumpleaños de un hijo tak
no puedo decir nombres pero ustedes me
entienden perfectamente las empresas
piramidales
tienen una gran capacidad de
manipulación del sentido de pertenencia
muchas veces la gente dice no pero yo me
siento mucho mejor desde que participo
en sus programas correcto porque te
hacen sentir parte viajan por el mundo
los mejores vendedores
se sienten identificados con sus pares
les va bien en el trabajo posiblemente
consiguen esposa novio lo que sea eso es
realmente un ejemplo perfecto es como
una religión comercial es extraordinario
ahora yo les voy a decir una cosa cada
vez que ustedes escuchen
vamos a llamarlo un político o si me
escuchan a mí reten me si yo en algún
momento digo la gente no es tonta la
gente sabe atención manipulación del
sentido de pertenencia activado vamos a
extraer este concepto la gente
qué es la gente el pueblo el pueblo lo
toman como si fuera un niño un indefenso
que no sabe nada
mucho peligro mucho peligro porque
porque todos nos sentimos parte del
pueblo es política y políticamente
incorrecto hablar mal del pueblo así que
por favor la persona que escucha en un
discurso político que dicen eso para en
la oreja
esta es la última parte de mi charla la
cual no les prometo que no se me caiga
una lágrima así que espero que cuando me
baje todos ven un fuerte abrazo y tiene
que ver con la trascendencia del sentido
de pertenencia recuerdan que yo les
conté que cuando era adolescente pensé
en quitarme la vida porque ya no me
sentía parte de ningún lado vino un
compañero del colegio en ese momento me
dio un abrazo y me dijo no te vayas
quédate por mí
11 años
seguramente alguno de ustedes es padre
de un niño de 11 años
qué bien habrán hecho a los padres para
educar un chico para salvarle la vida a
otro verdad desde ese día mi sentido de
pertenencia se debió a las amistades
esta foto que usted están viendo aquí
no me pueden reconocer por la cantidad
de pelo a mi cabeza pero soy yo
y es mi madre
mi madre liliana hay demás que ya van a
entender porque le estoy diciendo este
nombre
era lo máximo para mí era mi ídola era
todo
pero qué pasó no solo ella falleció dos
mejores amigos y mi padre también
sentí que me quedé solo con solamente 23
24 años a cargo de un montón de cosas
ahí fue que dediqué mi vida a la
filantropía y son temas que podemos
hablar en otra oportunidad pero lo más
lindo estaba por llegar
en uno de mis viajes yo sentía que tenía
que hacer algo por el mundo árabe no sé
porque lo sentía de esa manera
y una familia en dubai una familia
musulmán
con sus tradiciones totalmente
diferentes a mí
vio algo que no podemos no podemos
explicar hoy en día y me dijo no te
gustaría quedarte unos dos días en casa
ocho años viví con ellos
la familia al masri qué significan los
masri y de pura casualidad es el mismo
apellido que mi madre por eso yo uso
nicolás mango masri es en honor al a
ellos además de mi madre por supuesto
me enseñó lo que es tener una familia de
nuevo
esta foto fue el día que le propuse el
casamiento a mi esposa argentina también
en el comedor de su casa
también me emociona mucho
y poder honrarlos
con esta charla
poder haber dirigido ese sentido de
pertenencia a lo más hermoso me pasó en
la vida que es volver a tener una
familia otra vez
pero cuidado que esto se está quedando
corto
estas las familias suárez bolivianos
esto fue navidad pasamos navidad y año
nuevo juntos y mi cumpleaños y el
casamiento de mario que es el más alto
que está ahí de camisa celeste y gracias
a él conocí república dominicana
y por último quiero cerrar
con sergio y marisa mis padres de
españa' que fueron los primeros en darme
una familia cuando mi padre murió
esta charla
va dedicada a toda esa gente que sabe
que creando un sentido de pertenencia
más universal donde podamos
identificarnos todos unidos sin importar
nuestra religión sin importar nuestro
color de piel todos podamos trabajar
juntos y hoy más que nunca como
latinoamericano en un evento de este
tipo yo les quiero pedir a ustedes por
favor que entiendan el valor que no se
dejen manipular y que puedan aprender a
definir su sentido de pertenencia para
trabajar en equipo y hacer juntos una
latinoamérica mucho más fuerte mucho más
unida y mucho más justa muchísimas
gracias y esta plaza para ustedes
[Aplausos]